hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll if you've been paying attention
to advances in technology science or
just news in the world it's hard not to
be impressed with recent progress in
artificial intelligence mostly driven by
neural networks and deep learning
machine learning kinds of techniques
we've really been able to do things with
ai that when i was your age we just
couldn't do for one thing
artificial intelligence programs are
easily able to kick the butts of human
beings when it comes to games like go
and chess
which was considered very far away not
too long ago
another example is gpt-3 which you may
have heard of which is one of these
language processing things where you can
ask it a question or you can give it a
prompt in some sense and it will respond
or will continue on in the vein of the
words that you gave it on the basis of
the fact that it has read a lot of
things and it sort of looks for
correlations between them and finally
and maybe you know most importantly for
our everyday lives ai is everywhere
around us
in vision recognition you know
recognizing the images that are in front
of us maybe even self-driving cars or
something like that someday but
certainly recommendations what music to
listen to what movies to watch etc ai is
at work so on the one hand it's very
impressive on the other hand
none of these are going to be confused
for a human being none of these versions
of ai are going to pass the turing test
in some very advanced way you can sort
of
[ __ ] up versions of the touring test
that are passable by modern ai but it's
not a full-blown general intelligence
right agi artificial general
intelligence the kind of ai that would
really
fool you into thinking it might as well
be human so today's guest gary marcus
thinks that he knows why we're not able
to do that
more importantly he thinks that we're
moving in the wrong direction or
focusing on the wrong things to make
progress in this particular direction
the idea is that there are certain kinds
of things that neural networks deep
learning is good at
looking for correlations in gigantic
data sets there's other things that it's
not good at it's not good at
understanding in some vague sense that
we would like to define it's not good at
common sense that understanding how the
world works at a basic level so that in
individual circumstances we can apply
our knowledge in a kind of reliable way
that's why self-driving cars turn out to
be harder than we thought they would be
the world out there is a messy place and
you need a picture of the fundamental
way the world works not just a set of
correlations in your computer or at
least that's what gary would say
and he even has advice for how we can
make progress in the right direction
because there's been a shift in how
artificial intelligence research has
been done in the early days it was
symbolic you would try to define symbols
variables in your ai program that
represented different things and then
look for relationships where try to
define relationships between the
different variables whereas it's almost
more
mindless today the deep learning
algorithms just take in a whole bunch of
data and then spit out correlations
between them as gary points out
the best deep learning algorithms
actually are hybrids they actually make
use of the symbolic approach as well but
he still thinks we should be going a lot
further in that direction we really need
that kind of understanding based
approach to make artificial intelligence
of the kind you would recognize as
human-like in some sense and that might
not just be something we want to do
because it would be cool it might be
important technologically going forward
so we're going to dig into that it's a
lot of fun gary's very opinionated guy
he actually started out in neuroscience
and psychology before moving into ai so
he really cares about how real human
beings think he wants to make computers
think better than they do today so let's
go
do
gary marcus welcome to the mindscape
podcast
glad to be here
so we're going to talk about artificial
intelligence let me give a
my impression of the history very very
briefly so you can tell me whether i'm
correct or not like there was there were
go-go days of artificial intelligence
maybe in the 60s and 70s where we were
first getting computers that were up to
the task of even thinking about it and
people thought very soon we'd be talking
to them and having deep philosophical
conversations uh and then it didn't pan
out it turned out to be harder than we
thought
these days there's a bit of a resurgence
right i mean ai is kind of everywhere
neural networks people are thinking
about self-driving cars
and you're on the side of being a little
bit of a gadfly right he's saying like
okay yes we've had some successes here
but this is not going to be just smooth
sailing until we get real human level
intelligence is that a fair overview
yeah i mean i could pick some uh details
so i think the first bit of enthusiasm
was in the 50s
rather than the 60s and the first winter
the first ai winter which i think is
important was in the early 70s
when there was something called the
lighthill report i think 1973
that said hey this stuff isn't really
going anywhere we're putting all this
money into it but what are we getting
for it um and
research really slowed down then and i
think that the field
lives in permanent worry that that might
happen again
and maybe you should live in even more
worry uh than it does
um so you know that's that's a little
edit there um i would like to clarify
for the record that i love ai i'm not
someone who thinks ai is impossible
um i use the word gadfly i would
probably use the word skeptic and
i
to that point of that skepticism there's
both a specific and a general the
general thing
is
one of my favorite graphs i ever saw was
the prediction for how far or away let's
say artificial general intelligence
might be although the term is new but
the idea has been around for a long time
that you know how how many years until
we have ai that's actually let's say as
smart as people and we can talk about
whether that's even the right criterion
and you look and it's basically always
people say it's 20 years away classic i
always say you know
20 years from now so you know that
itself is a little bit of an object
lesson and then there's a question about
what is it that we actually have now
what have we made progress on and what
not and i know as a physicist you have
respect for the data and you have
respect for the fact that there's
different kinds of data and different
kinds of measurements and there are some
measurements on which the kind of i'll
call it the orthodox kurzweil notion of
exponential growth seems bang on
and one example for that is chess
playing another example is go playing on
these board games there has really been
exponential growth or even super
exponential growth um you know
you look at go now as compared to when i
was a kid and computers couldn't play it
at all i could be
a go
player now there's no way i could beat
alphago
so on on those kinds of things there's
been exponential growth
on some other things growth has been
slower than the popular media would have
it so
um you know
if you had read the popular media over
the last few years you'd probably think
that vision was solved that we now know
how to do computer vision how to
recognize the reality is we have
actually made progress there but we have
not solved the problem so i'm looking at
you right now um on a you know the zoom
type call
and um i guess your audience isn't
looking at the image line but i can
instantly parse what's going on there
right and not just label the objects but
i can actually
answer questions like there are things
on the wall and i can make guesses about
how they might be mounted there um and i
would be surprised if they started
floating around the room like i have an
understanding not just of the entities
but how they relate to one another i see
like stacks of books and their paper on
top of them and i understand you know
why the paper is not floating and not
falling
so i have this kind of integrated with
physics understanding of the scene and
ai does not have that and that's part of
what perception is so you know
every other month there's another study
now showing these so-called adversarial
attacks and so forth showing that these
vision systems can be fooled in fact
mostly they rely on texture and things
like that so one of my favorite examples
from recently was a um what was that i
think a fire truck overturned on a snowy
road and the system said with great
confidence that it sees a snow plow and
it did that because on a snowy road you
know if there's a vehicle it's likely to
be
the snow flower and these systems are
very much driven by textures that they
see and by kind of probabilities of what
things are generally likely they don't
have an overall understanding of the
scene another recent example was um
a uh i'm trying to remember what it was
it was something or other i think i
think it was
an apple with the word ipad on a piece
of paper in front of it right
and so you know it thought that that
that was an ipod because the word was
written on on the page
yeah so you know perception is not
actually solved but there has been
actual progress so that's the
intermediate case the first case was
true exponential progress then there's
perception where there are pieces of it
where there is exponential progress and
pieces of it not so much and then
there's natural language understanding
and reasoning and i would say we've not
really made progress at all you know
gpt3 which we may want to talk about
gives the illusion of having natural
language understanding but i don't
really think that it does
and we are nowhere near for example an
all-purpose general assistant we're
nowhere near to having the kind of
language you would want if you had a
domestic robot but i have a cartoon in
my book
where somebody says put put everything
in the living room away and the robot
ends up cutting up um with a saw the
couch right because it doesn't
understand what it is that we would mean
by put everything in the living room we
have no
candidate solution for that problem it's
not just that we've made no progress we
don't even know how to make progress on
that now you're making so sad that
there's no artificial intelligence
podcast editor that would that would
make my life a lot quicker
that would be great and i mean
you know even there there's an example
of like
how ai does actually help in some ways
so now there are tools if you want to
put together powerpoint slides um for an
online talk in this crazy era in which
we are living that will automatically
transcribe and do a pretty decent job
and then go find where the brakes are in
the word so like there are a lot of
places maybe that you wouldn't even
expect where ai is actually helping now
they're also somewhere it's hurting now
we should talk about those too but um
you know
ai is real now and it wasn't before and
that's both a blessing and a curse
because some of it's reliable and some
of it's not and you know there are all
kinds of problems with it but just on
that first question you know of history
and where we are now what i would say to
wrap up a long winded answer is we've
made a lot of progress on a lot of
things but there's some core problems
which are mostly about understanding the
world and what people are talking about
where we really haven't made that much
progress and it could be now we really
are for the first time 20 years away
um where all those other times with you
know we weren't um or it could be we're
still like 50 years away yeah the the
core question of how you use common
sense knowledge of the world in order to
interpret things so again back to the
scene in your room like also there's a
place where the lighting values are
higher and i can guess that that's
outdoors like making all those
inferences about what i see what's
likely to be going on we just don't know
how to do that yet and maybe it's good
to we
we're able to get into the details a
little bit the audience likes the
details so let's try to understand why
there has been this progress and as far
as i can tell the overwhelming majority
of recent progress in ai has been driven
by neural networks and deep learning
algorithms is that fair and and what
does that mean
it's true
but with some caveats so okay first of
all there are older techniques that
everybody takes for granted but you know
are are real and already out there
second of all there are things like
um alphago that are actually hybrid
models that use classical tree search
techniques and enhanced with monte carlo
techniques
in order to do what they're doing so
they're not just a straight
multi-layer perceptron as a kind of
stereotype that people have of neural
networks you have some inputs they feed
into a hidden layer that does some
summation and activation function goes
to an output they're not just that right
they actually borrow some important
ideas about search for example and
symbols
uh from classical ai and so they're
actually hybrid systems and people don't
um acknowledge that so there's a second
caveat i would give you um the
third caveat i would give you um we can
come back to the second but the the the
third caveat i would give you is yeah
most of the progress has been with deep
learning lately but most of the money
has been there too and it was really
interesting to see
i mean and i don't just mean like 60
versus 40. i mean like 99.9
of the investment right now literally um
is in deep learning and um you know
classic symbol manipulation ai is really
out of favor and people like jeff hinton
say don't spend any money on it at all
so it was really interesting there was
this competition presented at the
neurops conference which is the biggest
uh conference these days in the ai field
just a month or so ago on a game called
net hack that has various complications
in it and a symbolic system actually won
in an upset victory over all this deep
learning stuff and so
you know if you look back at the history
of ai in the history of science more
generally sometimes things get counted
out too soon it is true that deep
learning has made a bunch of progress
but the question is you know what
follows from there no i'm not actually
trying to make any value judgments i
just would like to explain to our
audience what the options are like what
do you mean by deep learning what is
that and what is that
in comparison to symbolic manipulation
each learning
is
fundamentally
a way of doing statistical analysis on
large quantities of data at least that's
you know it's forte you can actually use
it in a bunch of different ways but most
of the progress has come from that and
what's impressive about the recent work
is it allows us
to
learn from very large quantities of data
the classical ai system
really didn't do a lot of learning at
all they're mostly hand coded
and sometimes that's the right thing to
do so we don't need to learn
how to do navigation we need to learn
some details but we don't need to learn
how to do navigation for the purpose of
one of the most useful ai things out
there which is route planning telling
you how to get home from whatever crazy
place you've wound up in right right
that's not a deep learning driven system
but there are other systems where
if you can glom on to all the data
that's out there you can solve certain
problems very effectively and that's
what deep learning has been good for so
an example of that is labeling your
photos in let's say the apple photos app
or google photos or something like that
there what you really want to do is to
get user data
like measured in the billions or
trillions of examples
and have a system that can
extract from all of that data what is
the most likely label for this image
given the other images that are in my
database that have been labeled so
that's a kind of typical use of deep
learning is very good at and speech
recognition is similar so you know i
hear this word lots of people have said
it in lots of different ways and you
know i hear this particular sound is it
like
that collection of things that i've
heard before or this other collection it
turns out deep learning is far and away
the best and in some ways simplest way
to solve a whole bunch of problems like
that sometimes it's only a little bit
better than the other solutions and gets
more press maybe than it deserves but it
usually is the best for these problems
where we have billions and billions of
training examples it's usually okay but
the right way to go but what is it how
does it work it's statistics it's
correlations but how does it find these
correlations in in ways that we couldn't
do a few decades ago
so i mean the basic idea is not actually
new as a
something i should clarify first so the
mathematics around this has actually
been around for decades people had the
idea to do it before basically you're
just trying to figure out i have an
error how can i reduce the error that
i've made before
adjusting
weights between a bunch of things that
we call nodes that are supposed to make
make us think of neurons i mean we can
have a whole separate discussion about
whether they have anything really to do
with neurons but they're at least
loosely inspired
by neurons and you're adjusting the
weights between them sort of how loudly
they talk to one another and if one of
them talks too loudly to the other one
you find out over time well i should
make it talk a little bit more softly
and this one should talk more loudly and
you're basically doing that on a mass
scale
and it
turns out to work really well
the the math was rediscovered a bunch of
different times there's actually a
debate in
this mailing list called connectionists
right now about that history and people
periodically have these debates there's
no question that it's been around for a
long time what really happened is that
um people develop gpus for video games
that allow you to do
a lot of the relevant mathematics in
parallel at the same time and that
allowed people to do this deep learning
thing at a scale that they didn't really
even dream of 20 years ago um so that
was a major thing there's this paper
called the hardware lottery i'm trying
to think of a thinker named sarah hooker
wrote this really interesting um piece
about how the and i confess i've only
read the summary of i've read
um but her thesis is basically you can
have these accidents of history where a
particular architecture or something
like that is available at a particular
moment and people just run with it sure
and there's a little bit of that going
on here
and i don't know if she makes this
observation or not but it connects with
what she says
where
it's kind of partly an accident of what
we figured out how to parallelize first
that has made deep learning as popular
as it is so
you know it was clever to try to use
these chips that were built for
something else for the purposes of deep
learning and it really changed deep
learning i made a remark earlier about
you know unfairly dismissing things too
soon deep learning was unfairly
dismissed too soon so um i have
dismissed its ability to do sort of deep
cognition but that's a separate question
its ability to do basic pattern
recognition was actually in doubt so in
the early 2000s jeff hinton who's his
big star now is kind of like he gave a
poster at this conference nobody came
yeah he was like you know this stuff
doesn't really work story we understand
the math it's kind of cool it has its
own kind of elegance but you're not
really getting it to work so like forget
about it and to his credit he stuck with
it and once
people like him could use it at scale it
turned out that this technique is
actually lousy with small amounts of
data but it's brilliant with large
amounts of data and so it was actually
like a perfect storm so one of it was
one aspect of it was getting these chips
which made a huge difference another was
we didn't have
databases with trillions of examples you
know in in let's say the year 2000 you
know the internet it's the other major
technology that has driven deep learning
the internet means that you have large
amounts of data yeah and in some sense
that from your description it sounds
like
i mean it's artificial intelligence but
it's kind of dumb and kind of
straightforward right i mean you have
all these perceptrons these nodes and
they have weights and they just float to
whatever is the best at fitting the data
on the training set without any deep
understanding of what has happened as
you were talking about you know papers
do not float in the air or anything like
that so what's the how would you
characterize the alternative of uh the
symbolic approach i guess is what you're
calling it
yeah well let me um before i do that let
me say that i think that we need
elements of the symbolic approach i
think we need elements of the deep
learning approach or something like it
but it neither by itself is sufficient
so i'm a big fan of what i call hybrid
systems that bring together um in ways
that we haven't really been figured out
yet the best of both worlds but
with that preface um because people
often in the field like to misrepresent
me as that symbolic guy and i'm more
like the guy who said don't forget about
the symbolic stuff we needed to be part
of the answer okay so the symbolic stuff
is basically the essence of computer
programming or algebra or something like
that i mean what's really about is
having functions
where you have variables that you bind
to particular instances and calculate
the values out so simplest example would
be an equation in algebra y equals x
plus 2. i tell you what x is you can
figure out what y is and there it
doesn't matter which x's you have seen
before you have this thing that is
defined universally um it's the way a
logician might put it universally for
everything in some domain right um
you know any physicist would grasp that
immediately um
or any programmer or any logician and
that is the essence of what allows
programs to work so we're using a tool
called zencaster and it's putting the
bits together of your image such that i
can see you and vice versa and it's
doing this in real time because there
are functions that can do that across
any image then we might do some image
processing if we're on zoom to do
segmentation we could talk about that
but you know the basic thing there is i
have a function that says you know for
any set of bits i will do this function
and i don't care if this image is one
that i saw before and similarly if i
type something in the chat box it
doesn't matter if i come up with a novel
sentence or familiar sentence whereas
the deep learning stuff is all about
similarity to the things that you have
seen before right and so it's really a
different almost thesis about what
cognition should be and i think the
right thesis is actually our brains
anyway can do both we we can do the
logical abstract stuff and i actually
did experiments in all the way back in
the late 90s on human infants showing
they could do the abstraction even at
seven months old
so there's this ability for us to do
abstraction which allows us to be
computer programmers or to do logic um
and there's also this like heavy
statistical analysis that we humans do
we're not quite as good as the machines
at it but we can do a lot of it so we
know that the word inextricably is often
found by linked or bound but you know
never by water and we know a lot of
statistical things too um not at the
same scale but we're good at it and we
use it so we use it in parsing sentences
for example we make predictions about
what the other person's gonna say but
then again if the other person surprises
us we can usually figure it out so like
you know a lot of comedy is based on
saying something that isn't expected
right and having the the listener you
know figure out that thing and if you
had a system that only kind of makes
predictions like you can think of um gpt
three which is the most famous language
system right now as a really amazing
version of autocomplete and autocomplete
is you know pretty useful and we auto
complete to other sentences but we also
have to deal with the unexpected and for
that symbols are actually really good
and right this is why we need to bring
both of these traditions together well
you have the example in one of your
papers um that i really liked of
children learning how to make the past
tense in english where there's a rule
right you had ed
uh i i podcast i podcasted but then
there's all these irregular ones where
it doesn't follow the rule and so it's
kind of like for the regular verbs it's
a symbolic kind of manipulation and for
the exceptions it's more like a deep
learning kind of thing
exactly and that's actually what my
dissertation 1993
um was about exactly that it was it was
about these split systems in fact i
wandered off from ai for a long time
because i just found it kind of really
not very inspiring and came back
around the time of watson because i was
surprised that watson actually won at
jeopardy i can tell you why i think it
won but um i was surprised i'm not often
surprised and as a scientist when i'm
surprised that really like wakes me up
and so i was real woken to ai in in 2012
i guess or so by watson and then around
the same time deep learning was popular
i was like oh man i've seen this movie
before because the the
stuff that i was working on for my
dissertation which included those
regular and irregular verbs which steve
pinker called the fruit fly of um
cognitive psychology or something like
that um
all that it's the same issues
went into my thesis looking at how
children were doing things as come up
again now when we try to figure out what
can deep learning do for us and not and
it's like it can do the irregular verbs
it's not so great with the regulars
right but it's interesting because um i
mean so deep learning is very very good
at some things obviously we've had
tremendous
success playing chess playing go protein
folding is a new success uh that the can
we pause there though so so like sure
the the um
the success in the protein folding and
the success in the games actually depend
on hybrid systems and the the
media coverage of that
and even the
internal understanding the field doesn't
i think
realize how much the hybrid stuff is
important so for example if you just
took the deep learning part of alphago
and did not have all of the search stuff
the monte carlo search there it wouldn't
be that good and similarly alpha fold
has a whole lot of very careful
structured representations
around the nature of the
three-dimensional geometry that's trying
to solve and it's not just a simple
multi-layer perception i'll put in
arbitrary data get arbitrary data out
and i'm good to go so
you know
oftentimes the field kind of pumps up
the deep learning and doesn't really
talk about the other piece of it i'll
give you one other example um which is
open ai had this example of a system
quote solving the rubik's cube with deep
learning but if you actually read the
paper the part of it that i would think
of is solving which is like knowing
which face to turn when was done
entirely by a symbolic algorithm and
they didn't mention that the deep
learning was doing the motor control and
it was you know it was a nice
contribution to motor control not as
nice as they made it out to be but it
was you know a real
thing to be able to get the system to
turn in one hand um the rubik's cube at
the right time but the the cognitive
part of what should i turn in the
rubik's cube which is kind of the part
that makes it interesting to the average
person they pick it up and they can do
the motor control but they don't know
how to do the other part
that was done by a symbolic system and
none of the media accounts talked about
that and you know the the
there is a
a mystique associated with deep learning
right now but often it's actually just
part of the picture and that does just
gets completely lost sure but what i'm
trying to get at is the fact that these
successes don't easily generalize you
know we think about
chess and go as quintessences of
intelligent thought right but in some
sense they're really really simple the
rule set is very very simple and it's
mostly a matter of having enough
capacity and computing power to think
about it and you know obviously there's
a tremendous amount of cleverness that
goes into designing the algorithms and i
take your point that it's a hybrid kind
of algorithm
but my impression is that if you change
the rules of the game by a little bit
right you change the rules that you're
allowed to do with the stones with go or
how the pieces move in chess
um the the algorithm that was the
world's champion at the regular rules
wouldn't be able to adapt very easily to
the new rules whereas
whereas a human being could adapt pretty
quickly because it has more heuristic
understandings of what positions are
strong and things like that
yeah i i pretty much agree with that i
mean it could start over and learn a new
game of course i think that the the
things that the d minor build are are
pretty good at games that where there's
a closed world and you can gather an
infinite amount of data for free
so
related to your point in trying to scope
out what is the generalization and
generalizability so
these systems are good at closed worlds
where the rules are you know ideally
haven't changed in 2000 years and you
can play yourself and get as much data
as you want
they don't generalize as much to the
real world because you usually don't
have the same kind of fixed set of rules
and it actually is costly to get data so
you know if you're trying to figure out
what i should do today with my life you
can't get infinite data and you can't
solve you know i i have i'll give you an
example of an article that i had
somebody made
the article was with ernie davis in um
the acm journal and the illustrators
came up with this great picture which
was
um
we were talking about common sense
reasoning and the importance of it they
had the picture of a robot on a tree
cutting the limb from the wrong side
such that if it succeeded in the cut the
tree limb was going to fall down and so
was the robot and so that's an example
of something you can't get by infinite
self-play right you don't want to fall
out a lot of trees you want to have some
other way of getting to that source of
knowledge
if you can work in a hermetically sealed
problem where there's kind of no
influence from the external world and
it's always the same thing you can use
this kind of brute force um
approximation
but if you have to deal with things you
can't expect it's problematic now it's
problematic for other approaches too
nobody has a great ai solution to
dealing with the unknown so
you might remember when long-term
capital failed billion dollar epic mess
up you know a bunch of nobel prizes had
a model of what they thought would work
and they didn't realize that you know
you could have problems with the russian
bond market that would influence this
other stuff right that wasn't a deep
learning failure that was a failure of
models though yeah and we don't know how
to make models in general versatile
enough to deal with the unknown i mean i
was not a fan of rumsfeld but his point
about unknown unknowns is actually a
good one um human beings are better at
dealing with unknown unknowns
at least in some cases than any
technology that we that we've currently
developed so like if you imagine trying
to make a domestic robot right now
amazon's got something that they're
talking about shipping there's a lot of
stuff that comes up that nobody's
anticipated and if all you're doing is
kind of looking stuff up in a database
of what you've seen before at some point
that breaks down so to your point about
generalization you know nothing really
unforeseen happens in go if you've
played yourself 20 million times
but in the real world you know it's
snowing in vancouver and that's not
really happening and i need to cross the
street and i can't even see the street
and now what do i do right and you know
systems aren't really built around that
well we can see that there is there's
going to be some trade-off um between
letting the algorithm learn by itself
versus giving it some structure right
like you mentioned for the protein
folding where it's not just
consider every configuration in space
there's some pre-existing uh
ideas that are built in there my
impression is that for chess and go
the lesson was
don't spoil the algorithm by teaching it
human tricks because it'll learn faster
just by playing against itself
yeah i mean
that's true at this moment in the
history of ai i don't know that it's
always true so another weakness in
current ai is we just don't know how to
leverage existing knowledge we don't
know how to specify it and we don't know
how to use it there are some domains
where it's actually fine so we can do
like taxonomy so if i tell you that um a
penguin is a bird you can make a bunch
of inferences about that and realize
that it's going to breathe and reproduce
and
so there's some things where where we
can take a bit of knowledge and extend
it further but we don't know how
first of all in the case of go we don't
often don't know how to represent the
expert knowledge in some cases we do we
don't really know how to use it and it
turns out in that domain right now as
you say but with emphasis on the right
now it is easier just to do brute force
and just start over basically then to
have a bunch of expert go players tell
you stuff although you know that's there
was actually an expert go player on the
off was an author on one of these papers
and probably did say some things and
they're you know there are some things
that are built in because we know how to
do them like we know that it's rotation
invariant again as a physicist you know
what i'm talking about i can rotate the
board i can flip the board and basically
i wind up in in the
the same
conceptual space um
so there are some things we know how to
build in but you know here's another
example
a
general intelligence ought to be able to
read wikipedia and use all that
information in order to make all kinds
of decisions like to help us with
material science or medicine or whatever
and we don't have systems that can do
that it can sort of like take the
results of hard-won human knowledge or
it could be about you know almost any
domain
and put them in so right now the systems
right now the systems that we have are
mostly kind of blank slates they
get whatever they know by having all of
those
nodes line up and and balance out in in
the right kinds of ways
um
without any or without much
influence from the knowledge of the
world and
it's cool when it works and in some
domains it works well and others it
doesn't but like here's another case
driving you would like to be able to
just put in the rules of the california
driver's code
and stick it in with your deep learning
system but we don't know how to do that
you just don't
well language is a great example and i
you know you've alluded to it several
times already uh uh gpt-3 is the system
that everyone talks about these days um
i mean maybe you could tell it's just
what how gpt3 works what's so
interesting about it to me to be honest
i'm less impressed with its results than
many people seem to be
well i may be even less impressed than
you are but many people are that it's
true in fact most um
to me it's a kind of parlor trick that's
actually a mistake in in the evolution
of ai um
what it does is another it's another of
these systems more complex than the one
that we talked about before but it's
still basically about setting weights
for connections it has some prior
structure around attention to help it
know about relations between words over
um certain space and time there are
things called positional encodings and
um and we don't have to go into all the
technical details but the the
basic
uh framework if you will or
is you get a prompt it sees some set of
words
and then it predicts what might follow
and in this way it's kind of like the
mother of autocomplete um
so you can type in anything and it will
continue
in that same style
in some ways it's astonishing so you
know you type in something that looks
like a movie script and it'll like
continue
you know often with the same characters
in the same format and and
all of this um as a kind of surrealist
generator it's fantastic yeah type in
part of a story and it will continue the
story um
so why am i
not enamored of it when it's capable of
doing some really cool things like i
would not dispute that it can do really
cool things um oh and i also like it's
capable of being really grammatical
which earlier systems were not right um
and it's kind of astonishing in how it
does that nonetheless i think that it's
misguided um
and i think it's misguided because
there's no real semantics there no
there's no
underlying understanding of what it is
talking about
and
this manifests in different ways so um
it will give you fluent speech i wrote
an article that was supposed to be
called gpt3 [ __ ] artist the the um
the editor wouldn't let me call it that
so i think it's called gpt3 bloviator
conclusion which is that it's a fluent
spouter of [ __ ]
um and we had examples like this you're
thirsty you have some grape juice but
not enough so you look around you find
some cranberry juice you sniff it you
pour it into your glass and then you and
gpt
autocompletes and so it says then you
drink it which is plausible
statistically speaking as a continuation
and then it says you die
you know most people don't die by having
cram grape juice you know it's usually
pretty harmless stuff so this system
doesn't actually understand anything
about toxicology or why you might die
it's just statistically speaking the
probability of the word die after you
sniffed and you're thirsty in some
corpus that it is you know learn from
happens to be high and i think that
illustrates what's really going on there
is it's just looking for corpus through
the corpus for correlations it doesn't
understand what those correlations are
about and that leads it to a weird
position in terms of what it does you
can't type in an idea and have it
formulate that idea in words which is
what classic computational linguistics
tries to do it can only do this game and
then people work around this game of
i'll feed my thing in and hope that it
continues and what they wind up for
example with is a lot of toxic speech
and deep mind just had like you know 10
people working on the problem and
actually they're hundreds in the field
trying to make these things not be as
toxic and yeah there's no solution there
because you just have the correlations
you don't have an underlying system
where you can like query it the way you
could query a database you could query a
database and say you know how many
people of this age group are here or
whatever you can't query gpt and say are
you making a toxic remark or are you you
know singling out a group it doesn't
know it's just statistical correlations
between words and so people are trying
to put all these band-aids on top of it
to make it less toxic but it's not going
to happen the technology does not really
afford that and it has a truthiness
problem so it's very fluent and so it's
easy for it to make stuff up and you not
notice and so you know it
it will make up whatever you know
anti-vaccine stuff if that happens to be
in the database it has no idea what what
it is that it's spouting
and well and
you use it against the band-aid that we
solve it exactly you had an analogy
which i thought was very illuminating
with the guy who won a scrabble
tournament in french even though he
spoke no french because he just sort of
memorized a list of french words that
would be really useful in scrabble
yeah i went back to that book by fatsis
to
try to find i think those people called
them word tools or something like that
like they don't know what the words are
so they're just using word tools and
that's exactly what's going on that's
why i don't even like playing scrabble
against other people because if they're
good then they've memorized all these
little words that you know fit for two
letter words man that's where it's at uh
terrible but uh
i mean the thing that got me i i was
actually before i understood what it
really was about and i had seen some of
the hype about gpt3 i thought maybe it'd
be fun
to do a podcast where i interviewed gpt3
and had it you know uh voice synthesized
but then i realized the very basic fact
that it has no memory so it doesn't
remember what you just talked about one
question before and so there's really
just no after five minutes it becomes
highly unamusing
i'm doing an art project around that
notion and you know i did some
interviewing of gpt and i would ask
questions like are you a computer
and it would say yes they would say are
you a person it would say yes like the
very next sentence
so why not why why can't you just
add some memory in there is that what is
the conceptual leap that makes it hard
or is it just that this is a really good
question it's that that's an a question
there um for sure the the
what is it about the nature of the
system that makes it non-trivial to just
add memory and some people have tried um
certain kinds of things it's just built
from the foundation in a different way
it's built from the foundation to
correlate little bits of information
like the probabilities of these words
following those words and it's not built
to have a representational scheme it
does not contact a representational
scheme about these are the entities in
the world and these are their properties
it's just built like on a completely
different path
and you know maybe there's some way of
merging them and i do think that
ultimately the answer to ai is going to
come from merging at least some of the
insights from the gpt tradition with
some of the insights from the more
classical ai tradition but i don't i
don't think it's going to come literally
from merging gpt
with these other systems because gpt
does not have the internal
representations that you need
um you know it'd be like saying i've
written this big computer program
but i'm not going to let anybody else
see what's inside of it and now i just
want you to hum and i hope that they
match together they're not you know
yeah there needs to be some planning to
make them do some planning around what
are going to be what we call technically
the interface conditions
um
and it doesn't have it doesn't have an
api
to use you know computer gate terms an
api where you can
say hey what are the people that you're
talking about right now what are the
assertions that you've made about them
what are you presupposing and you can't
build the api because it isn't there
i mean it seems to me like sometimes it
looks like it's there because it looks
like it's
coherent but it's a superficial illusion
of the fact that it's drawing on this
vast database of things that people have
said you can't build the api to do it it
seems like this is a pretty strong
argument just by itself for
deep learning or that kind of
statistical correlation to be a tool
used by a symbolic manipulator like you
know that you need some view of the
world that is represented symbolically
but then by all means have some
deep learning help you with what the
correlations are to predict what's going
to come next
well there's a narrow version of that in
a broader version i guess the narrow
version i think is actually wrong and
the broad version i think is right so
the broad version is
yeah
we need to have symbol systems
rely on learning systems to do some of
their grounding about what those symbols
are about
um and i think that's the broader
argument that you're making i think it's
just right the narrower version i don't
think gbt itself is actually the right
tool for doing the grounding because it
doesn't
have
those interface conditions it hasn't
been built from the ground
to land in the right place so like
you're trying to have two sides of the
bridge or the tunnel i mean meet up and
it just wasn't built that way um but i i
think the idea of building that tunnel
um
is right of like let's figure out what
these systems are good for like there
are lots of opportunities in the world
to be tracking correlations but you need
to have respect i think for where you're
trying to wind up and
as a cultural matter as a sociological
matter the deep learning people
for about 45 years have been or no
actually like 60 years have been
aligning themselves against the symbol
manipulating tradition okay well now
this is why we're on the podcast we're
going to change that
sorry say again that's why we're having
this podcast we're going to we're going
to change it you're doing your i was
about to say it might be changed a
little bit so jeff hinton who's the best
known person in deep learning has been
really really hostile to symbols it
wasn't always the case in in the late
80s he wrote a book about bringing them
together um and then he at some point
went off like completely on the deep
learning side now he goes around saying
deep learning can do everything and he
like told the eu don't spend any money
on symbols and stuff like that but jan
lacoon one of his disciples actually
said in a twitter reply to me yesterday
you know you can have your symbols if i
can have my gradients okay which
actually sounds like you know yeah
compromise right so i was kind of
excited to see that that does sound good
sometimes people can like say they're on
opposite sides but really be uh pretty
close to each other
there there's one example i want to get
on the table because it really made me
think and i think this is the time to do
it which is the identity function you
talk about this in your in your paper so
let's imagine you have some numbers uh
they go through a process that spits out
an output from the input and every
single time the output is just equal to
the input so you put in one zero zero
one zero binary number and it puts out
the same number and you make the point
that every human being sees the training
set you know here's five examples and
goes oh it's just the identity function
i can do that and extrapolates perfectly
well to what is meant but computers
don't or deep learning doesn't
yeah deep learning doesn't i don't think
it means that computers can't but it
means that what you need to learn in
some cases is essentially an algebraic
function or a computer program
part of what humans do in the world i
think is we essentially synthesize
little computer programs in our heads we
don't necessarily think of it but the
identity function is a good example i'm
just my function is i'm going to say the
same thing as you or you know we can
play like simon says and then you know
i'm going to add the word simon says to
the ones that go through and not the
ones that don't go through very simple
function that you know five-year-olds
learn all the time
and it's done
as a function that applies to a whole
bunch of different inputs so you can say
simon says touch your finger to your
nose or simon says put your your phone
in front of your nose or simon says put
your wrist strap on your head or
whatever um your viewers can't see me
doing these ridiculous things but i'm
glad you're laughing um and so you can
do this on a you know infinite set of
things and that's really what functions
are about and what programming is about
doing these things with an infinite
range um
identity this is the same as that you
learn the notion of a pair in cards you
can do it with the twos and the threes
and the fours and now i make a new deck
i don't have twos and threes and fours i
have i don't know stars and guitars and
you can tell me that a pair of guitars
means two guitars you've taken that new
function put it in a new domain that's
what deep learning does not do well
right it does not go over to these new
domains there are some caveats around
that but in general that's the weakness
of this system and people have finally
realized that um nowadays people talk
about extrapolating beyond the training
set but that the paper that you read um
i don't know which version but i first
was writing about this in 1998 um
is really capturing that point it took a
long time for the field to
realize that they're actually different
kinds of generalization it also goes
back to the past tense stuff so people
said there's no problem our systems
generalize and i said no there's these
special cases and finally now they're
saying oh there are these special cases
when you have to go beyond the data that
you've seen before and really that's the
essence of everything where things are
failing right now so let's take driving
you know these systems extrapolate or
sorry interpolate very well in known
cases
and so they can you know change lanes in
the environments they've seen and then
you get to vancouver on this crazy snowy
day that nobody predicted and you don't
want your driverless car out here um
because you now have to extrapolate
beyond the data and you really want to
rely on like your cognitive
understanding where the road might be
because you can't see the lane marker
anymore but i think that's the kind of
reason they can't do it your identity
function example it raises an
interesting philosophical question about
what the right rule is because it's not
like the deep learning algorithms just
made something up but you gave an
example where the training set all with
a bunch of numbers that all ended in a
zero and the other ones were you know
random and so we figured it out but the
deep learning just thought the rule was
your output number always ends in a zero
and the thing is that that is a valid
rule you know it didn't just completely
make it up but it's it's clearly not
what a human would want
the conclusion to be so i've been
talking about this for 30 years i've
made that point in my own papers be the
first person to ever ask me about it
well how do we formalize the way to my
heart it's yeah it's really a deep and
interesting
point right
it's not that even when these systems
make an error
it's not that they're doing something
mathematically
you know random or something like that
they're doing something systematic and
lawful but it's not the way that we see
the universe and in certain cases it's
not the sort of functional thing that
you want to do
and that's very hard for people to grasp
so for a long time
people used to talk about deep learning
and rule systems it's not part of the
conversation now as much as it used to
but they would say oh well the deep
learning system learns the rule that's
there and what you as a physicist
understand or what a philosopher would
understand is the rules are under
determined by data you need something
you know there are multiple rules the
easy example is if i say 2 4 6 8 what
comes next you know it could be 10 but
it could be something else and you
really want some more more background
there so it turns out that deep learning
is mostly driven by the output nodes the
the sort of
the the
nodes that at the end giving the answer
and they each learn things independently
of one another
and that leads to a particular style of
computation that is good for
interpolation and not so good at
extrapolation and people make a
different bet and i did these
experiments with babies to show that
even very young people make this
different bet which is we're looking for
tendencies that hold across a class of
items we're looking for the rule that's
just how we're built sometimes that gets
us in trouble there's there's a word
apophenia which is like looking for
patterns that aren't even really there
yeah um and you know so sometimes it it
doesn't serve us well but it very often
does and language is a great example
where it serves us really well you learn
a grammar and then you can apply it to
any words that you can throw in that
grammar even novel words so if i told
you that this thing was called a blicket
then we can start talking about blickets
right away i can say how much did that
blicket cost you would you sell me your
blicket would you recommend the blicket
is there something an alternative to the
blicket like you know you're off to the
races with one training example because
you put it in the context of something
that is rule governed where you have a
grammar that tells you not only the
syntax blicket the pluralism the
morphology is going to be blickets and
it's going to tell me how i can use it
with verbs and now but also semantics
you can know that i probably mean an
individual object a single object that i
can go and count and you know all this
kind of stuff like right away because
you have a world model that you map your
language onto that's what it's really
about well and this is exactly where i
was going to go with this because
what is the way that clearly you know
with all this setup we need to give our
world model to our computer friends to
our artificially intelligent friends and
how do we do that is it that we human
beings need to formalize our sort of
manifest image of the world our picture
of common sense and then turn it into a
bunch of symbols or
is it and i'm sure that i think i know
what the answer to this is could we deep
learn our way into common sense you know
could we just is there a way of letting
computers figure out the same kind of
common sense that we have
i take a view that i think is a little
like what kant was trying to say in the
critique of pure reason although i'm
never sure i've completely understood
that book but um
you know he talks about having basically
prior knowledge of space and time um and
i'm sorry i haven't read your book which
would be super relevant at this point
um but i i think and so i i like to hear
your take on it but
my view is you can learn a lot but that
you need a framework to learn
to to embed that knowledge and so
minimally i think you need to know that
there is space that there is time that
there is causality that there are
enduring objects in the world and some
other stuff but like stuff like that and
i believe that there's some reasonable
evidence from the animal literature and
the human infant literature to think
that these things are in humans innate
i think you need to start with that or
else you just wind up with gpt um in
fact i think gpt is a brilliant
experiment unintentional but brilliant
on the idea of could you just learn
everything like let's say from words or
from you know people haven't really done
it from pixels but i think you'd wind up
in the same place and i think the answer
is no
you you don't wind up with the api i'm
talking about if you don't have prior
notions about enduring objects that
you're talking about then you just
you're just in correlation soup and it's
you know made the best job of
correlation soup that i've ever seen but
it's still correlation soup and it
doesn't really
connect to those things which means that
it can't know that it's ridiculous to
say i'm a computer and a person in one
breath or two breaths um you know it it
doesn't have the framework to know that
like things don't tend to change too
much over time because it doesn't know
what time is so
i don't fully have an answer to the
question that you posed a minute ago but
i think it starts by saying we're going
to learn some stuff but it's going to be
rel relative to
a framework where we have some basic
knowledge about the world to start with
that there are these enduring objects
etc i mean just to emphasize how tricky
all this is you know it i think it maybe
undersells the difficulty if we just
think about there's space and there's
time and there's objects and they have
solidity because there's also you know
number one there are relationships
between these objects there are
functions that they have you already
mentioned causality you mentioned the
fact that
there are values you don't chop up the
sofa to put it away because that's
something that is already away in some
sense and so it's going to be quite a
trick and i guess what you're saying is
i think i think i agree
you're saying that the computers are not
just going to
learn all that stuff by looking at
correlations but but there's a still
tremendous program out there in front of
us of figuring out what it is we want
them to know ahead of time yeah so the
the
most impressive shot on goal to use a
kind of cliche i've heard a bunch lately
in canada
is uh right no but i heard it a lot
around the vaccines and you know rightly
i think people said this is going to
work there's so many shots on goal
um
and and they did um
we underestimated the human capacity to
ignore data but that's another
issue um
so
um
doug lennon
built this thing called psych which you
may or may not know about
cyc
he's done it for the last 35 years and
it was an attempt to put all of common
sense knowledge or a large fraction of
common sense knowledge in machine
interpretable form and it hasn't been
the home run that he thought it would be
and
i think people have drawn the wrong
lesson from his lack of a huge obvious
success so like he didn't build google
with it right um
and you know he may have hoped that he
would have
um
but i still think it what he was trying
to do was right i think maybe it failed
because it started too soon with a
different set of tools than we would do
to use the project that he was trying to
do but i think the project is right that
we're not going to solve this in
ai problem
or general intelligence problem without
having a lot of knowledge in formats
that the machine can leverage so you
know you need to know if you're
predicting about grape juice and
cranberry juice that they're both juices
and that other things being equal you
can mix juices together and you won't
die or whatever um and there's a
question about like what level of
specificity you want all of that stuff
to be in do you want to derive
everything from like you know quantum
mechanics do you want to have
intermediate representations at the
level of juice which is what people do
but you need some kind of knowledge that
machines can reason over and
he built something like 1100 micro
reasoners that that reason over things
like economics and
i don't know if beverages are in there
or not but you know lots of
little domains and and desires the most
impressive thing he has and i write
about this in an article called the next
decade in ai and give a reference to his
article which might be in forbes or
fortune so i can't remember which
he goes through this example with romeo
and juliet where
the system is actually able to reason
about something complicated like what
juliet thinks is going to happen when
she drinks this potion that's going to
fake her death that's really
sophisticated stuff and he shows that
his system that has this common sense
knowledge can make good inferences
around that and nothing in the deep
learning tradition can do anything like
that and it's a proof of print you know
conceptual proof proof of concept that
if you have the right knowledge you can
actually get machines to do really rich
inference but there's also an asterisk
around it which is like
it doesn't just read
the shakespeare and make this inference
rather he has converted the shakespeare
into a set of logical propositions and
then the system is able to reason over
those logical propositions and so i
guess the skeptic would say well that's
the whole he's left out the whole
problem i'm a little bit more optimistic
i think he has left out a huge problem
but also showed that another part would
be solvable if if we do one piece of it
um
but it's there's a whole interesting set
of issues that don't even get talked
about that much which is like
can we really do this without knowledge
sort of like what he's doing my answer
would be no we need something like what
he's doing but also that he did it in
the 80s and we know a lot about for
example statistical representation of
information that he didn't have the
tools um to use then so like you want a
lot of distributional information you
don't want to just
discretize things into logical bins you
also want to know like what's typical
and um he doesn't have a lot of that
kind of stuff represented so like you do
it differently if you did it now but i
think what he was trying to do is still
of the essence i'm reminded of several
years ago chris anderson who was the
editor of wired at the time wrote some
little piece saying that theory is dead
in science my least favorite article of
chris anderson is in the wired
and
his logic was look if we have enough
data we can just figure out what all the
correlations are who needs a theory and
i wrote one of the responses uh and i
said look
tycho
tico i should say brahe the famous
astronomer collected a lot of data and
uh people like kepler his his protege
found some correlations in the data and
constructed some very useful rules and
that was good but it was when isaac
newton came along and invented a theory
to explain why kepler's rules were there
that was when we really understood
something because then we could talk
about beyond you know going
extrapolating beyond the data sets etc
so in some sense maybe the the worry
about or the problem with deep learning
is that we're too good these days at
being tico and kepler because we're able
to manipulate these huge data sets but
true understanding won't come until we
are able to abstract a simple set of
rules which will be a little bit more
robust than the original data sets
well i mean i think even getting to
kepler would be progress and that most
of the
work in the sort of ai scientific
discovery stuff builds in the answer in
some way or another and like you know
what kepler did that was awesome was was
to kind of come up with his own answer
he wasn't like
you know choosing from three templates
or something like that like there's a
really cool paper by josh tenenbaum and
um charles kemp where they see data and
they infer like does this follow a
ladder or a circle or whatever these
kind of conceptual relationships but all
the choices are built in the beginning
yeah and
what and like it's still a cool paper
but the the really cool paper which
nobody knows how to write i don't know
you know either would would actually
induce that these are even the the
logical forms that you should think
about and that's you know maybe that's
closer to what newton did but i would
give kepler some credit for that too you
know there's a problem some people
sometimes talk about about
extracting like what the variables are
that you even want to talk about
and
i think that's
often the the critical thing or
sometimes you know there's a billion
different choices and you need to know
this is the one that i care about um
it's actually impressive even the
children ever learn what integers are
for example
this is the kind of thing that
you know
if i was still a professor i retired as
a professor young but um
um if i was still a professor i would be
telling everybody work on this problem
how is it that um and susan carey is
actually telling people this how is it
the kids actually figure out what
integers are
right that's an example of a
kind of conceptual apparatus that's
incredibly valuable
and yet
you know it's not obvious that it's
innate like it's pretty obvious that
number is innate so know so many animals
have some conception of approximate
number you know that 12 is more than
seven like any animal can
most animals can figure that out um but
knowing what a discrete countable system
is where you can have infinity you know
that's a pretty cool intellectual
accomplishment and kids do it they do
the same thing when they learn to read
some kids don't but most of them do
um a harder example is fractions you
know the median split on sats apparent
sat math is apparently do you really get
what fractions are or not
um
do other primates understand
this say again do other primates
understand integers
you can get them to count you know the
extent to which they understand integers
is not
totally agreed on okay um i don't know
if there's some controversy in the
literature they can at least do things
like remember a sequence of
small integers
um you know whether they get to the
point of realizing hey i could just keep
going with this forever if you just
teach me the right words for it i don't
know well it goes right into what i
wanted to ask next which is the extent
to which being inspired by biology and
evolution and actual human reasoning is
useful right like evolution
uh
is not goal directed it was not set up
to try to build a perfect computer and
the human brain is really good at
driving and talking and and not so good
at playing chess or multiplying big
numbers together uh do you think that
we can take how evolution got us to
where we are as as inspiration for
this program of of uh i think the right
word is inspiration right so you know
there's this field of biomimicry and i
think that the
the
moral of that story is there's often
useful stuff and then there's stuff you
don't want to copy so like you don't
want to build your theory about how to
support objects around the human spine
is a terrible solution to supporting you
know this heavy thing right on the top
of the stock and that happens to be
there because we were quadrupeds and it
was kind of evolutionarily cheap in the
sense of being likely um to rotate the
quad head you know 90 degrees and then
your vertical and your biped and it's
great but really like a tripod would
have been a whole lot better and so like
you don't you don't want to copy
everything about our design in fact i
wrote a book called cluj which was about
all the things i think are lousy about
human cognition yeah starting with you
know or focusing on things like
confirmation bias where we notice
evidence for our own theories and you
know our political system right now is a
epic morality tale in in confirmation
bias and how bad that is so you don't
want your ai system to be subject to
confirmation bias where it comes up with
theories notices evidence for those
theories pats itself on the back and
ignores the counter theories like the
last thing in the world you would want
an ai system to do
so we don't want to copy
biology but we do want to learn from it
so we want you know there are things
that people still do way better than
machines even though there are things we
do really poorly um so we wouldn't want
to copy the memory systems people
because they're not that great but on
the other hand they're cue driven in a
way that's kind of cool and maybe we can
kind of do that now i know
but the way that people can
understand semantics in relation to a
syntax that's really interesting we
don't know how to do that with machines
maybe we'll figure out a better way to
do it than people do but right now the
only game in town is people so let's you
know see if we can learn from them can
you explain that that that issue without
uh we're defining the word semantics and
syntax as you're using them
i mean that issue is how do you relate
the meanings of words
to the ways in which you assemble them
and derive the meaning of a sentence in
terms of its parts yeah and you know it
turns out that
gpt can actually replicate the assembly
of the parts into a grammatical sentence
but it can't relate that to a situation
in the world that is being described by
its sentence
and it certainly can't go
you know back we can't actually go in
either direction you can't give it a
situation in entities and expect a
sentence that will validly describe them
um nor go the other way and get the
sentence and figure out whereas you and
i that's what we're doing sometimes
imperfectly but we're we're trying to
grasp each other's meanings so you're
you're building a model what is gary is
actually saying there right and you know
we have a limited bandwidth and whatever
but you know we get there and the
machines don't really have that
capability right now in a general way i
guess i'm just wondering how much uh you
went back to kant a little while ago but
how much innate knowledge
in the human brain is crucial to this
kind of reasoning that we do when
extrapolating and is that something that
would help us figure out what to build
in to a good hybrid ai system
i mean first thing i'll say is it's
controversial nobody knows i spent you
know the first two-thirds of my career
as a developmental psychologist
cognitive psychologist thinking very
deeply about this i wrote a book called
the birth of the mind which was about
how you might get innate structure given
the tools of developmental neuro or
molecular biology and what we know about
developmental neuroscience and so forth
and you know so i thought about these
things a lot and the honest answer is we
don't know exactly what's innate the
best work i think is done by elizabeth
spelke a developmental psychologist at
harvard um
but you know there's a lot of work out
there um
my best guess
is that we have at least about a dozen
things that are innate and there could
be a lot more so um a dozen things
include things like the ability to
represent these abstractions that we
were talking about the ability to
distinguish between types and tokens so
like know that this water bottle as
opposed to water bottles in general
space time causality all those kinds of
things are like
form a bare minimum and i've written
about this occasionally um and then you
could have a lot more i often point to
the
last chapter of pinker's uh first
popular book the language instinct where
he runs off a list of like 15 things
that includes like i think i'm quoting
verbatim mental rolodex and maybe that
is innate um you know some things you
might be able to derive if you had
others like if you had a cost benefit
system which i think is innate and you
had abstract variables and you had a few
other things maybe you could acquire
some of the others and then there's a
tension in the developmental psychology
literature or i'll actually
just call it attention a mistake a
foundational mistake which is that
people think that if something could be
learned it is not innate but that's
wrong right so think there may be many
things that could be learned but maybe
biology has chosen so to speak and you
know all the ways in which i'm being
anthropomorphic but has you know
alighted upon solutions to make those
innate because it's a whole lot safer or
faster or whatever so you think about a
baby ibex scrambling down a mountain it
is not working out online the physics of
objects and and slopes and stuff like
that that is there in that maybe or
where a honeybee can calculate the solar
azimuth function and extend it to
lighting that it's never seen before um
if you do the the right experiment so
there's clearly innate stuff there
about physics and observation and and so
forth so there may be a lot more than
just the 10 or so things that i'm
talking about but even those 10 have
made me kind of like public enemy number
one in the machine learning world where
where they want to learn everything from
scratch and they're like why is gary
always on about this and nate and stuff
you know how do you know
um
i think that the
one of the biggest problems with the
field of ai is that right now it is
dominated by
a group of people who do machine
learning and there's the old saying of
to a man who has a hammer everything is
a nail and so
the people in machine learning have made
astonishing progress in some ways in the
last decade and so they think that the
tool that they have is the tool right
whereas i think the right thing is say
congratulations that is an awesome tool
we thank you for it now let's see how we
could use it in combination with other
tools to do even more awesome things but
it's been a bitter battle getting people
even think about that well one of the
possible ways of thinking about this is
yeah i
i kind of don't want to think of alpha
go or whatever as intelligence almost at
all like it's it's a very good a playing
go
but it doesn't remind me of a human
being in in very many other ways
i mean i i i would say that intelligence
is multi-dimensional yeah and some of
the things that i think are fairly
counted as intelligence or like doing
that kind of computation and it's fine
call it as long as you realize that it
is multi-dimensional and there are other
dimensions where you know it's not even
showing up to bat so you know one
definition of intelligence is like
adaptively solving unknown problems and
it doesn't have that at all yeah
well and is is the general goal of
trying to make a.i
equal the capacities of human
intelligence the right goal or should we
just oh we shouldn't do equal we should
go for exceed
danny kahneman and i had this
conversation
we sort of came up with this phrase
together in a way it was a panel or
whatever which is humans are a low bar i
think that was his
right and i said
and yet we still can't exceed it yet
right we you know
we we surely should want our machines
not to be human level intelligence but
to be way smarter than us so you know we
we want if we're going to trust ai as
much as we seem to want to
um
it's got to be good right you know if
we're going to put it in charge of stuff
whatever that stuff is
um you know
it better be able to not be subject to
confirmation bias it better not just
perpetuate you know racist stereotypes
from the past but actually be able to
put values so that it's not just
interpolating but extrapolating to the
world that we want to have right and
that means it's going to be better than
most people or better than all people
you know that should be what we're
aspiring to um what we're settling for
now is we've got these cool tools and
they can do some stuff and sometimes
they actually you know tell people to
commit suicide or say racist things or
whatever and we're like but you know but
i get really good recommendations from
amazon so it's okay
and like that's where we are now it's
i'm not super thrilled with that
but
but
i guess what i'm getting at is i mean as
you said i completely agree that there's
very many different kinds of
intelligence and
uh
computers are going to be it's going to
be easier to make computers good at some
kinds of intelligence than it is at
other kinds of human intelligence and
i'm sure both are important but you know
how do we balance just
putting computers to work at the things
they're good at versus trying to nudge
them to become good at other things that
we human beings know and love
i think it starts with what you just
said i often make
your point a slightly different way
which is that um
people talk about artificial
intelligence as if it was one thing but
it's actually many things it's actually
a whole family of algorithms and also
databases and
and so forth that
have different properties they're good
at some things they're not good at other
things that's going to change over time
so there's the ai of
2022 is different from the aif 2019 and
i sure as hell hope that the ai of 2025
is better than what we've got right now
because it's problematic now
um
and you can't just talk about it like
it's a magic wand it's not it's it's a
it's a set of tools that are more or
less appropriate to certain problems and
so it's totally fine to use current ai
for photo tagging 2025 ai will be even
better at it but the cost of getting a
mislabeled photograph is generally not
that high unless then again you're using
it for surveillance in which case maybe
it's really high so you know i just saw
another one of these examples of
somebody who like went to jail because
an ai system misread something there's i
think in the in the book we gave an
example of
something in china that that gave
somebody a speeding ticket because their
face they were an actress their face was
on a bus that went faster
you know and
so the wrong person that you know
convicted of the crime
you know the the tools are are really
appropriate and then not appropriate
depending on how they get used so you
can tolerate the error in photo tagging
if you're not using it to identify
criminals if you're identifying
criminals then you probably need at
least 2025 ai or whatever you know 2030
ai because it's
the stakes are so high um same thing
with suicide prevention like you can
write a little chat bot that'll make
people feel better some of the time but
when the stakes are high i don't think
the tools we have right now are up to it
um driving is another example it's easy
to build a car that can follow a lane
you can have like 70 hours of training
data nvidia show this and you can follow
a lane and that's great but it doesn't
mean that you know what to do on a snowy
day um and so you know we have to be
very careful about the laws around
driverless cars and you know like right
now i think elon musk is beta testing on
public roads i don't think that's cool
there's been some accidents um
and so
understanding that ai is actually a
heterogeneous thing rather than a single
magic wand is important now that makes
it hard right because people want a
policy that's sort of about ai writ
large and that doesn't match the reality
of we are incrementally developing
science and engineering to make things
better and we understand some of it and
not others
and without asking you any uh to make
predictions about time scales or
anything like that do you see any
obstacles to ai being just as good at
human beings as human beings are at you
know writing poems or symphonies and so
forth in principle no
i mean
they're not going to have the emotions
um
you know that might drive some of that
stuff
it's actually not that hard to write you
know knockoffs of of bach without the
yeah um already
without the emotional resonance um so
you know i mean one piece of your
questions about specifically about
creativity and then there's a larger
question so many particular things that
we would define as creative we can
already build machines to do without
that connection to the underlying
emotional impulse that might lead to
something and so like
vocals are hard because vocals are
really about emotion um you know
synthesizing a drumbeat you know logic
12 or whatever is the latest edition can
do that pretty well right yeah you know
there's a humanized function to add a
little random variation and make it
sound like a person you know there are
certain things that we can do you know
very very well um and in some cases have
been able to actually for 30 years and
like people are reinventing them with
deep learning but people already knew
how to how to do some of those things um
the the larger question
um well sorry one more thing there are
some artistic endeavors that i think are
way beyond current computers though um
like a movie right where you have to
have coherence over a long period of
time so you know jpt can actually make
advertising jingles that are like
two-liners pretty well but it can't keep
the coherence that you would need for
you know for an ordinary film you could
make something you know something from
the late 60s
pharmaceuticals involved that seemed
interesting um
but
the long form is not the strong point of
what we have right now and it won't be
for a while um but i don't think
anything
in the
realm of cognition is impossible right
you know we are just computers and and
you know we don't quite understand how
those meat computers work but there are
information processors that you know
take in information and manipulate it
and come up with outputs that's what our
brains do and computers you know get
better at that and i don't see any like
principled argument that says 500 years
from now people will still be smarter
than machines i just don't see it 500
years is much safer than 20 years i
think you've chosen wisely about your
your time horizon there but i guess um
you know there are people who are
worried about existential risks from ai
taking over and have different values
than us um do you share those worries i
mean clearly giving ai's value systems
at all and recognizable to us uh is is a
tricky situation
so i wrote this piece in 2012 called
moral machines for the new yorker um i
was one of the first people to talk
about trolley problems um in in ai um
where in my particular case in the new
yorker article was a school bus is out
of control you're on a highway you know
should you sacrifice yourself a lot of
people picked up on this later obama
talked about um
i now have some regret around that
um it's all your fault we've narrowed it
down okay
i mean there were a couple of us who
wrote about it around the same time but
i was one of the first um but the thing
is that the real challenge right now is
much lower to the ground than that and
it's not often that you actually come up
with the school bus um but
you know asimov's basic laws
you know don't do harm just think about
that one like the the
model that we have now is around images
i show you a bunch of images
and you learn from those images to
recognize another it doesn't work that
model doesn't work for harm
i can't show you a bunch of pictures of
harm and really get you to grasp the
concept of what harm is we just don't
know how to program what harm is we
don't know how to program
really any human values into
current technology and it's actually
related to stuff we've been talking
about throughout the whole conversation
which is it's kind of an interface thing
we don't know how to specify these
things in terms that learning systems
would understand and we can't really do
it
entirely with innate set of rules either
there has to be some learning we have to
give some examples
um
there was a film called chappie a few
years ago where a robot learned
its values and you know
one of the lines in the film is is the
robot is trying
to figure this stuff out all out and
he's been the robot's been captured by a
bad guy
and
it's
the robot's master has said um you can't
kill people and the bad guy is a bit
disappointed to discover that the robot
knows this
because the bad guy would actually like
the robot to kill people but the bad guy
is clever and he works around and he
says yeah you can't kill people but it's
okay to harm them
and the robot is sort of you know left
yeah to construct its own own ethical
values based on the input that it's
getting and the reality is that we will
get to a point where
maybe that already have gotten to a
point where it would be really nice to
have ai systems with values and we have
not gotten to the point where we know
how to program that in so you know one
of the problems with gpt3 is all the
toxic language that it produces because
it's like trained on like the worst of
reddit and stuff like that and um we
just don't have like that already it
would be nice to constrain these systems
such that they would follow some set of
values and you can argue about what that
set of values would be but we we don't
know how to do it you know deepmind just
had like 10 people 20 people working on
this problem and came up dry like
nobody knows how to actually constrain
these systems to values um they don't
have the apis to plug into and you know
it's a problem so then when you come to
the existential stuff
i'm not worried about it now i'm not
worried about in the short-term robots
taking over the world they don't care
about us they have no motivation to do
so and they're frankly dumb right now
you know the ability to win a go doesn't
doesn't count for anything i mean glow's
actually a great example because go is
about territory right and
they don't actually understand anything
about territory in the real world
getting better at go has not made them
any more desirous of human territory nor
taught them anything about you know that
would be useful in an actual battle like
i'm not too worried about those kinds of
things in the near term the near term
i'm worried about
misapplication of the ai that we have
now um
but you know in 100 year time frame
it could it could be an issue i think
it's fine that we have a few people
around thinking about these issues now
even maybe they never come to pass
um but it's it's good to have some
thought into it it's not an urgent need
you know i'd like to end on an
optimistic an optimistic note so maybe
you know what if everyone listened to
you what if what if you were you're not
the bad boy of ai and everyone said you
know what more symbols more variables
more hybrid approaches to to join up to
our deep learning how would you see
ai going in the next uh few years well i
wrote a piece um for the times where i
argued for the cern for ai if people
really listened to me that's what they
would do
and i would get people to gather around
a particular problem
um in part because
otherwise if you have a large sum of
money then people just do their own
thing and don't actually coordinate
and the the problem that i would
coordinate them around is having an ai
that could read and understand the
medical literature i think there would
be enormous value in that you could also
maybe think about doing the same thing
around climate change
read and understand material science and
and so forth like either of those would
be fine in my my view
um
but have people coordinate around
machine reading and not i'm not talking
about like keyword matching which we can
do very well right now but having a
system read a scientific literature come
up with experiments based on um you know
what it reads come up with novel
solutions and so forth like i think that
could change the world
um and it would certainly push ai
forward so if you know if i were king
for the day that's what we would do all
right now uh people know it they can
spread the word gary vargas thanks so
much for being on the weinstein podcast
thanks this is really fun
[Music]
you